>> Before we get into the details of
image processing and building models for computer vision,
let's start by examining what an image is.
Now, to you and I, an image,
like a photograph, is a visual representation of something.
In this case, it's a photo of landscape,
and includes a plane or train, and an automobile.
To a computer program,
this image is made up of a matrix of pixels,
each pixel having an intensity that's represented as
a numerical value between 0-255.
Now in fact, this image is a color JPEG image.
So, it's actually a three-dimensional matrix,
with channels for red,
green, and blue pixel intensities.
For each pixel in the matrix,
the intensity values across these three channels
combine to create a full spectrum of colors,
and varying the pixel values in each layer,
changes the overall visual effect.